contre l'impérialisme américain nous le
sommes nous le sommes a priori
parce que nous pensons que c'est une
politique néfaste
qui
établit la priorité de quelques-uns sur
la domination du plus grand nombre mais
l'intégrisme en lui même ne veut pas
être jugé sous le new cream
l'impérialisme et dans cette vaste lutte
qui oppose les nations et les classes
entre elles une certaine forme de la
lutte je puise être contre elle et je le
suis totalement mais ça ne veut pas dire
que je considère a priori dans toutes
les circonstances des gentils ou comme
criminel ça n'aurait pas de sens
messieurs bonsoir c'était l'un des
multiples engagements de jean paul
sartre l'un de ses combats contre les
ismes nous on voulait toujours
l'appareil ou qu'on voulait toujours lui
opposer alors quand un grand comme ça
s'écroule victime de l'âge au terme de
trois quarts de siècle faut éviter
d'utiliser des mots les mots comme ils
disent elle emmène ses derniers livres
élites et de vous faire la lecture de
ces hommages innombrables venus du monde
entier et qui s'entassent au domicile de
simone de beauvoir et de sa fille
adoptive arlette qui toutes les deux
hier soir était autour de lui lorsque à
9 heures à l'hôpital broussais il fut
terrassé par un oedème pulmonaire dans
sa 75e année jean paul sartre qui sera
enterré vendredi vendredi après midi au
cimetière du père lachaise le voici au
travers de la biographie réalisée par un
juge devait décider que j'avais dit tout
ce que j'avais à dire disait-il c'était
déjà beaucoup cinquante ouvrages quinze
mille pages beaucoup de livres inachevé
mais combien de chefs-d'oeuvre il y a
des inachèvement qui porte haut et loin
le regard des hommes comme des
symphonies l'un des premiers contacts
avec le monde du jeune jean paul sartre
né en 1905 fut justement la musique il
appris le piano et jusqu'à ce que ses
yeux puisse déchiffrer les partitions
ils jouaient de la musique chaque jour
reçu premier à l'agrégation de
philosophie devant simone de beauvoir il
ne devait plus quitter le jeune
professeur sartre aller faire de la
littérature un absolu avec lui
condisciple de facultés et d'esprit paul
nizan maurice merleau-ponty raymond aron
il voulait faire une oeuvre et devenir
célèbre lui qui souhaitent écrire une
littérature philosophique et une
philosophie littéraire dès 1938 ce fait
il publie la nausée portrait d'un homme
incapable de conquérir sa liberté son
premier roman un chef-d'oeuvre
1940 à 1945 l'oeuvre de sartre explose
coup sur coup il écrit deux romans l'âge
de raison et le sursis deux pièces de
théâtre les mouches et huis clos mais
surtout un ouvrage philosophique majeur
l'être et le néant autant de livres
exposants le principe fondamental de sa
français qui allait devenir
l'existentialisme pour ça l'existence
précède le destin l'homme est libre est
condamné à être libre il a donc le choix
de sa vie un choix de chaque instant qui
remet sans cesse en question le piège
des institutions et l' angoisse de ne
pouvoir confier à quiconque sa
responsabilité d'homme la vie devient
une aventure
l'homme est à inventer chaque jour il
est avant tout un projet une entreprise
inévitablement il est donc seul
abominablement on comprend alors ce mot
célèbre jamais nous n'avons été plus
libre que sous l'occupation
c'est idéal et bouleversé la jeunesse
d'après guerre notamment à saint germain
des prés mais aussi trois générations
d'intellectuels dès lors son rayonnement
est intense et internationale il coupe
le fil ténu qui le reliaient encore mais
si peu à son enfance bourgeoise son
engagement est total non conformiste il
le restera jusqu'au bout ce qui ne
plaira pas à tout le monde son toboggan
des mots comme il dit lui inspire des
pièces de théâtre qui sont aussi des
succès les mains sales le diable et le
bon dieu plus tard les séquestrés
d'altona des essais sur jean genet
baudelaire en 1960 la critique de la
raison dialectique
des scénarios de films dont les jeux
sont faits et le troisième tome de son
roman les chemins de la liberté sartre
voyage avec simone de beauvoir sartre
réfléchi sur le marxisme ils s'engagent
de plus en plus il agit il se révolte on
a toujours raison de se révolter et
curative il combat la guerre d'algérie
le retour au pouvoir du général de
gaulle condamne l'intervention
soviétique en hongrie comme il
condamnera celle de prague il se remet
sans cesse en question recherchent
l'authenticité de ses actes en disant 24
il refuse le prix nobel de littérature
parce que l'écrivain ne doit pas se
laisser transformer en institution
contre les crimes de guerre américains
au vietnam il participe au tribunal
russell il dira à son dégoût de cette
guerre à la télévision
le massacre de sols nus et pour le
comparer le massacre d'oradour ce sont
des formes de
lutte anti populaires c'est-à-dire la
réaction d'une armée régulière à une
lutte de résistance qui est menée avec
ray le concours du pack sartre
redoublent d'énergie en 1968 il est du
côté des étudiants bien sûr et les
défend comme on dit que mode aimant il
se gauchise veut se supprimer en tant
qu'intellectuel parce qu'elles sont
interdites ou menacées de l'être il
prend la direction d' agences de presse
et de publications d'extrême gauche
comme la cause du peuple ou libération
il les distribue dans la rue avec simone
de beauvoir jusqu'au contrôle d'identité
du plus grand philosophe français de ce
siècle jusqu'au procès
bravant les scandales il parcourt
stuttgart dénoncer les conditions de
détention d'andreas baader le plus
redouté des extrémistes et allemand
quelle impression vous a donné andreas
baader
d'être maigre très maigre à cause les
aides de la fin qui fait d'abord un
visage assez torturé mais d'avoir parlé
très calmement qu'est ce qu'il avait à
me dire vous avez dit dans plusieurs
interviews que vous étiez globalement
solitaire de andreas baader mais que
vous n'acceptiez pas tout à fait ces
méthodes est ce que vous pensez la même
chose après l'avoir vu oui c'est à dire
que il y à différentes méthodes qui
permettent à gauche de lutter contre les
forces qui sont opposés au mouvement de
gauche est la sienne et peut-être
valable en allemagne je ne sais pas mais
une richesse en france à partir de 1975
il perd l'usagé de la vue et cesse
d'écrire ils seront encore à l'elysée
pour plaider la cause des réfugiés du
vietnam fuyant leur pays la situation du
vietnam est encore très difficile
et comme leur système communiste ne
plaît pas à tout le monde est évident
que ces gentilles ont pu d'ailleurs
combattre pour rejette nam nouveau est
lâché oui un certain temps
dans ces conditions
l'opinion de ses jambes sheikh le
vietnam ne nous importent pas
qu'il n'aime pas de régime est
actuellement qui est établie mais ça ne
nous regarde la regardent eux et les
populations d'état mienne ce qu'il ya
c'est que sont des hommes en danger
mortel et ce sont ces hommes qu'il faut
se courir parce que ce sont des angles
rester le dialogue avec des amis les
entretiens avec des journalistes ou
simone de beauvoir couture et de
contradictions mais inflexible sur le
chemin célébrer et hi hi jean paul
sartre avait la passion de comprendre
les hommes il écrivait aussi c'est
phrase devenue célèbre et qui terminait
les mots dits je range l'impossible
salut par la littérature au magasin des
accessoires
que reste-t-il tout un homme fait de
tous les hommes et qui les vaut tous et
que vaut n'importe qui n'ont pas
n'importe qui
donc je vous le rappelle les obsèques du
philosophe dans l'après-midi père
lachaise et antenne 2 fera de ce
vendredi une soirée spéciale jean paul
sartre apostrophe à 9h30 et puis ensuite
la chambre réalisé par l'un des
meilleurs adaptateur de sartre michel
mitrani et puis là le match de bus en
apprenant la nouvelle le chef de l'état
n'a pas souhaité que le conseil des
ministres évoquent publiquement la
mémoire de jean paul sartre ce n'était
pas le désir de l'écrivain qui rejetait
tous les honneurs valéry giscard
d'estaing a toutefois ressenti cette
disparition en tant que jeunes lecteurs
de ses oeuvres dans les années de la
guerre et la libération s'était dit il
une des grandes lueur d'intelligence de
notre temps toutes les réactions à la
mort de sartre sont d'ailleurs autant
d'hommages à son génie nous les abordons
dans une deuxième partie de ce journal
tout entière consacrée aux philosophes
mais auparavant plus rapidement le reste
de l'actualité
l'actualité sociale tout d'abord à
commencer par enfin un peu de répit sur
le front du chômage le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi a baissé le mois
dernier selon les statistiques
communiquées ce matin par jean matteoli
au conseil des ministres il y a trente
cinq mille 300 demandes de moins qu'au
moitié brillé mais le chiffre des
demandes d'emploi non satisfaites reste
très élevé un million quatre cent douze
mille les détails de ces statistiques
chaque mannino
comme beaucoup d'autres phénomènes
économiques et sociaux le chômage obéit
à des cycles ainsi chaque année et vous
le voyez sur cette courbe le chômage est
relativement stable entre octobre et
février il diminue ensuite jusqu'à la
sortie des classes en juin pour remonter
régulièrement et atteindre son point
culminant en janvier mais ce bon
résultat du mois de mars trente cinq
mille chômeurs en moins n'est pas
simplement due à ce mouvement habituel
des statistiques il est également la
conséquence d'une économie qui tourne
quoi qu'on en dise assez fort l'an
dernier nous avons fait un taux de
croissance de 4% ce qui est parmi les
pays occidentaux l'un des taux de
croissance les plus élevés autre raison
de ce bon résultat le troisième pacte
pour l'emploi des jeunes qui avaient
démarré assez lentement qui commence
maintenant à porter ses fruits au 31
mars dernier quatre cent mille personnes
avaient pu être placés grâce à ce pacte
cette légère amélioration de l'emploi se
traduit aussi par une baisse du chômage
partiel ou à 40% en un an et par une
régression du nombre des licenciements
économiques moins 15% sur la même
période il reste malgré cela que
l'emploi demeure bien sûr le problème le
plus préoccupant trois chiffres le
montrent clairement
près d'un demandeur d'emploi sur deux
exactement six cent mille ne reçoit
aucune indemnité près d'un vendeur
d'emploi sur deux a moins de 25 ans ils
sont exactement sept cent mille et sur
ces sept cent mille et bien un cent
mille ont une formation égal ou
supérieur au baccalauréat enfin la durée
moyenne du chômage reste longue sur dix
demandeurs d'emploi quatre d'entre eux
sont inscrits depuis six mois ou plus à
la npa
coupures de courant un peu partout en
france aujourd'hui en raison de la grève
des électriciens-gaziers cgt et cfdt à
paris un grand défilé a rassemblé des
manifestants venus de toute la france
le cortège s'est rassemblé devant le
ciel de l'électricité de france avant de
se rendre
l'esplanade des invalides les
manifestants réclamaient une
revalorisation des bas salaires une
diminution du temps de travail et
protestent contre deux propositions de
loi visant à limiter le droit de grève
et les droits sociaux
poursuite de la grève précisément des
nettoyeurs du métro parisien les
travailleurs des sociétés privées ont
repoussé à l'unanimité les propositions
patronales le conflit dure maintenant
depuis 24 jours françois ceyrac était il
y à une heure l'invité de face au public
sur france inter il a longuement évoqué
les projets de loi sur la participation
disputés actuellement par le parlement
s'est montré assez sceptique sur ces
projets considérant que l'on est en
train de mettre dans l'entreprise un
double système le système traditionnel
at il précisé qui existe déjà et puis en
plus un système électoral aux
syndicalistes et je vous rappel sur ce
point que le projet de loi sur la
distribution d'actions aux salariés a
été adopté la nuit dernière par
l'assemblée nationale cela dit les
députés donne est aujourd'hui
l'impression de penser à tout autre
chose m'a dit daniel brême en fait à
deux affaires entre nîmes et les
affaires poignée de ski et persiste la
sphère peyrefitte vous ne connaissez pas
encore alors je vous raconte c'est pas
un texte publié par le canard enchaîné
aujourd'hui et qui est attribué au garde
des sceaux une lettre au chef de l'état
le mettant en garde contre jacques
chirac et lui conseillant en janvier
dernier de l'affaiblir en réduisant les
gaullistes et en les séduisants surtout
réponse d'alain peyrefitte tout à
l'heure dans un communiqué je décline
toute responsabilité à la garde d'un
texte que je n'ai ni écrit ni signé
le dossier payet d'auxi de breuil
maintenant contre attaques de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur ce matin il va
poursuivre le ps et le pc et il va
demander une importante indemnisation
qui servira au financement de la
campagne présidentielle du candidat de
mon chemin a dit il le candidat de mon
choix et je crois que là on a une petite
idée et monsieur premier de ce qui n'y
va pas de main morte cinq millions de
francs à chacun des partis socialiste et
communiste
un million de francs au député georges
fillioud n'allait plus virulent à son
égard dans le vent la riposte ponia
s'affole réponse ce soir jorge celio
depuis trois cents mille francs à chacun
des députés signataires de la saisine de
la haute cour si le bureau de
l'assemblée venait à prendre des
décisions politiques c'est dire si la
sphère en tout cas le dossier prend de
l'importance mais oui je crois qu'il
faut essayer de voir clair et de séparer
un peu les différents niveaux il ya
d'abord un niveau qui est proprement
judiciaires c'est l'instruction sur
l'assassinât de jean de braye il y a
trois ans et vous savez que la semaine
prochaine mercredi la cour d'appel doit
décider s'il ya lieu ou non de rouvrir
le dossier le garde des sceaux rappelait
à l'assemblée nationale il ya quelques
jours que cette juridiction est
souveraine c'est dire qu'elle doit
échapper à toute pression politique bon
alors là le niveau politique précisément
et la démarche fameuse des communistes à
bord et les socialistes voilà nous
sommes effectivement en pleine politique
car si la haute cour est un tribunal
c'est un tribunal politique politique
par sa composition ce sont des députés
des sénateurs politique aussi par les
personnes qui peuvent être différés
c'est à dire le président de la
république où les membres du
gouvernement et puis aussi la décision
de saisir cette eau secours est une
décision politique ou plus exactement
parlementaire c'est dire que cette
procédure ne pourrait aboutir que si le
rpr venait à s'y associer l on sait
depuis hier que le rpr ne s'y
associerait que si le dossier n'était
pas ouvert on est renvoyé donc là à la
sphère judiciaire que nous évoquions
doute à l'heure où six affaires
politiques michel poniatowski se refuse
à s'expliquer devant la justice alors là
ils acceptent de faire puisque lui-même
porte plein ou alors s'ils portent
plainte cela veut dire que sa réplique
est d'abord une réplique de caractère
juridique mais là il ya quelques
problèmes car le parti communiste et le
parti socialiste ne peuvent pas être
poursuivis ce ne sont pas elles n'ont
pas d'existence juridique ce sont ce que
l'on appelle des associations de fait
quant aux députés signataires et bien
ils sont protégés par la constitution
qui dans son article 26 précise qu aucun
parlementaire ne peut être poursuivi
pour des votes ou pour des opinions qui
auraient été émis dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions or au demeurant le ton de la
déclaration de michel poniatowski qui
est une déclaration très vigoureuse le
fait qu'il soit prêt à retirer sa
plainte que me le disais tout à l'heure
et or gaston defferre tout à l'heure en
séance à l'assemblée nationale d éclater
une sorte de chantage exercé par michel
poniatowski sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale tout cela montre que
finalement la réplique de michel
poniatowski est essentiellement une
réplique politique et nous assistons je
crois à une espèce de d'escaladé dans la
transformation d'une affaire judiciaire
en affaires politiques ont un peu
l'impression que chacun fait monter les
enchères tout en sachant que ces
démarches et initiatives
ont peu de chances d'aboutir mais il
s'agit en cela surtout de s'adresser à
l'opinion publique mais alors là sur le
plan judiciaire ajoute une information
contre x pour dissimulation de documents
rien être ouverte le juge d'instruction
a décidé d'ouvrir cette information à la
suite de la plainte de pierre de varga
qui est l'un des inculpés de l'afertes
de breuil enfin puisque nous parlons des
affaires toujours entre guillemets le
jugement du procès qui opposait jacques
et françois giscard d'estaing a minute
et au canard enchaîné chacune des
publications doit donner un francs de
dommages et intérêts à françois giscard
d'estaing minutes doit le faire pour
jacques giscard d'estaing qui en
revanche est déboutée de sa demande en
dommages et intérêts au canard enchaîné
neuf morts dans un incendie la nuit
dernière à marseille une famille entière
décimé une mère et son fils de 15 ans se
sont jetés dans le vide du huitième
étage d'une hlm qu'ils habitaient et les
sept autres enfants sont morts
carbonisés et asphyxié dans
l'appartement marqué l'art joubert
dans le sous sol de cet immeuble de
marseille à une heure du matin que le
feu se déclare un feu qui provoque
probablement une fuite de gaz très
rapidement les flammes se propagent par
la gaine des compteurs à gaz au dernier
étage une famille avec huit enfants le
père locataire de l'appartement ouvre la
porte d'entrée et provoque un appel
d'air puis il ne la referme pas
l'ouverture d'une fenêtre double ensuite
cet appel d'air à ce moment là la mère
est là des enfants se jettent par la
fenêtre tandis que les autres péri
carbonisés leur père réussit à fuir le
feu neuf morts donc mais neuf morts par
affolement et imprudence tous les autres
locataires de l'escalier ont respecté
les consignes de sécurité fermeture et
calfeutrage des portes et ont été sauvés
par les pompiers
à l'étranger georges marchais en voyage
à beyrouth depuis hier a été accueilli
chaleureusement par le parti communiste
libanais et par plusieurs membres du
comité exécutif de l'olp et le fatah
général du parti communiste français
s'est prononcé pour un état libanais
liban uni et indépendant il a également
pris une position très ferme face pour
une plate forme pour que la france
agissent efficacement
pour la création d'un état à l'autre
palestinien
les objectifs l'aide que nous soutenons
et pour laquelle nous luttons nous
estimons qu'il corresponde aux intérêts
légitimes du peuple palestinien et plus
généralement aux intérêts des peuples
qui sont épris de liberté et de paix
toujours l'étranger en bref deux groupes
de réfugiés ont quitté d'après-midi cuba
pour le costa rica la plupart des exilés
sont jeunes de 20 à 35 ans environ mais
il n'y avait pas mieux que trois femmes
et un enfant c'est 250 personnes ont
voyagé à bord d'un boeing de la
compagnie costa ricaine le président du
pays est venu les accueillir en personne
à l'aéroport de 5 rosaire il rend les
étudiants islamiques ont fait savoir
qu'ils étaient prêts à recevoir la mère
et le beau père du sergent herning qui
étaient nos invités hier soir dans ce
journal le vous savez que ce sergent est
l'un des otages détenus à l'ambassade
américaine
les étudiants islamiques ont quand même
demandé que ses parents acceptent les
modalités qui leur sont imposées par eux
mêmes je crois que c'est une affaire qui
est à suivre et puis dès demain le
président carter pourrait annoncer de
nouvelles sanctions contre l'iran mais
on sait d'ores et déjà que ces sanctions
ne comprendront pas un blocus naval de
lire enfin tchad l'intensification des
combats sur le front sud les forces
d'hissène habré se sont violemment
accrochés hier avec la retirer du vice
président sudiste hisséne habré qui se
trouve maintenant complètement
encerclées puisque au nord les forces
armées populaires du président goukouni
maintenant bien en main la situation
va faire des jo de moscou alors que les
sportifs japonais se prononce pour une
participation individuelle christian le
grès qui est le président de la
fédération équestre française a laissé
entendre que les cavaliers français
n'irai pas à moscou et même si les jeux
étaient maintenues la fédération
française rejoint ainsi la position des
fédération équestre américaines
britanniques allemandes suisses et
canadiennes qui avait déjà décidé le
boycott et cette décision des cavaliers
pourraient préparer un éventuel retrait
des athlètes français aux jeux
olympiques
donc maintenant notre édition spéciale
sur jean paul sartre jean paul sartre
sera inséré incinérés on vient de
l'apprendre la levée du corps est prévue
vendredi à 15h45 pour les proches
l'hôpital broussais et à 4h30 ce sera le
rendez vous
et les sept autres enfants sont morts
carbonisés et asphyxié dans
l'appartement marqué laroche joubert
si dans le sous sol de cet immeuble de
marseille à une heure du matin que le
feu se déclare un feu qui provoque
probablement une fuite de gaz très
rapidement les flammes se propagent par
la gaine du compteur à gaz au dernier
étage une famille avec huit enfants le
père locataire de l'appartement ouvre la
porte d'entrée et provoque un appel
d'air puis il ne la referme pas
l'ouverture d'une fenêtre double ensuite
cet appel d'air à ce moment là la mère
elle a des enfants se jettent par la
fenêtre tandis que les autres péri
carbonisés leur père réussit à fuir le
feu 9 lors donc mais neuf morts par
affolement et imprudence tous les autres
locataires de l'escalier ont respecté
les consignes de sécurité fermeture et
calfeutrage des portes et ont été sauvés
par les pompiers
à l'étranger georges marchais en voyage
à beyrouth depuis hier a été accueilli
chaleureusement par le parti communiste
libanais et par plusieurs membres du
comité exécutif de l'olp et le sauvetage
général du parti communiste français
s'est prononcé pour un état libanais
libre uni et indépendant il a également
pris une position très ferme face aux
problèmes palais nous sommes pour que la
france agissent efficacement
pour la création d'un état palestinien
la gamme diesel sont les objectifs
faibles que nous soutenons et pour
laquelle nous luttons nous estimons
qu'il corresponde aux intérêts légitimes
du peuple palestinien et plus
généralement aux intérêts des peuples
qui sont épris de liberté et de paix
toujours l'étranger en bref deux groupes
de réfugiés qui les aident après-midi
cuba pour le costa rica la plupart des
exilés sont jeunes de 20 à 35 ans
environ mais il n'y avait pas mieux que
trois femmes et un enfant c'est 250
personnes ont voyagé à bord d'un boeing
de la compagnie costa ricaine le
président du pays est venu les
accueillir en personne à l'aéroport de
sainte rose en iran les étudiants
islamiques ont fait savoir qu'ils
étaient prêts à recevoir la mère et le
beau père du sergent herning qui étaient
nos invités hier soir dans ce journal le
vous savez que ce sergent est l'un des
otages détenus à l'ambassade américaine
les étudiants islamiques ont quand même
demandé que ses parents acceptent les
modalités qui leur sont imposées par eux
mêmes je crois que c'est une affaire qui
va suivre
et puis dès demain le président carter
pourrait annoncer de nouvelles sanctions
contre l'iran mais on sait d'ores et
déjà que ces sanctions ne comprendront
pas un blocus naval de lire enfin tchad
l'intensification des combats sur le
front sud les forces d'hissène habré se
sont violemment
accrochés hier avec l'artillerie du vice
président sudiste hisséne habré qui se
trouve maintenant complètement
encerclées puisque au nord les forces
armées populaires du président goukouni
maintenant bien en main la situation
va faire des jo de moscou alors que les
sportifs japonais se prononce pour une
participation individuelle christian le
grès qui est le président de la
fédération équestre française a laissé
entendre que les cavaliers français
n'irai pas à moscou et même si les jeux
étaient maintenues la fédération
française rejoint ainsi la position des
fédération équestre américaines
britanniques allemands suisses et
canadiennes qui avait déjà décidé le
boycott et cette décision des cavaliers
pourraient préparer un éventuel retrait
des athlètes français aux jeux
olympiques
donc maintenant notre édition spéciale
sur jean paul sartre jean paul sartre
qui sera ainsi incinérés on vient de
l'apprendre la levée du corps est prévue
vendredi à 15h45 pour les proches à
l'hôpital broussais et à 4h30 sera le
rendez vous au père lachaise aucun
discours n'est plus rien donc en
compagnie dé paix - qui fut celui dont
gendarmes sans rien de dire que c'était
le dernier des maîtres de la pensée
française et dont libération écrivait ce
matin qu'il occupait le siècle comme
voltaire et hugo le fuyard pour l'heure
françois châtelet
je crois qu'il est difficile de
caractériser l'oeuvre de sartre par un
jour en isme puisque précisément ça est
toujours été l'ennemi des systèmes
l'ennemi les doctrines l'ennemi du tout
faits c'est un philosophe
essentiellement de la liberté et moi ce
que j'ai aimé en lui ce pourquoi je le
respectais je mets mais c'est que fils
m'a appris à me défier
précisément de toutes les écoles que
c'est un philosophe qui a non seulement
défendu la liberté dans ses textes mais
qui a essayé lui même d'être libre dans
sa recherche libre par rapport aux
formes culturelles puisqu'il a été aussi
bien philosophe homme de théâtre
cinéaste libre par rapport aux autres
forces politiques
puisqu'il a changé la vie et pourquoi
pas libre quand à même sa vision du
monde il a évolué il a découvert à un
moment donné de sa vie qu'il fallait de
prêter la parole à ceux qui ne parlent
pas les émigrés et tous les marginaux
tout ce qu'on qualifie absurdement de
marginaux et je leur ai même signalé une
chose d'un peu paradoxal dans cet
hommage auquel je participe c'est que
c'est que jean paul sartre on lui a
souvent refusé la parole à la télévision
1 il ya quelque chose d'un peu étrange
là il faut qu'ils soient morts pour que
brusquement on pense que lui
je content qu'on lui refusait la parole
où on n'a pas accepté les conditions
qu'il mène il était exigeant et ça aussi
c'est une qualité remarquable qu'il a
acquis qu'il avait cette volonté de
d'aller au fond des choses de ne pas
s'arrêter en route ce qui leur
reprochaient au marxisme c'est non
seulement son caractère autoritaire
c'est aussi le fait que c'était une
doctrine simplifiant t réductrice qui ne
laissait pas les singularités les
individualités s'exprimer et c'est
pourquoi il a été un aussi remarquable
essayiste
sartre est sortie de l'avant scène au
niveau des modes mais il est resté au
oui pour les étudiants au niveau de la
pensée oui oui c'est une c'est une
référence constante
précisément parce qu' il est l'homme
et qui
s'est efforcée de trouver le
frémissement et la diversité du réel et
non pas du tout simplement des pages les
unes à côté des autres
une publicité toutes les déclarations
des uns et les autres je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de celles du président et
public sont pour le ministre disait dans
le même temps que sartre a sans doute
été le plus grand philosophe de notre
temps et ceux des générations de
français le penser qu'il avait formé
l'intelligence et l'éveil de millions de
lycéens c'est donc quelques uns d'entre
eux que dominique laurie est allé voir
tout à l'heure au lycée henri iv
là où précisément le philosophe fut
élève en cinquième et en sixième
peut-être qu'il y a actuellement une
sorte de trou dans la philosophie
actuelle parce que si on se demande qui
pourrait remplacer sartre c'est
difficile de trouver quelqu'un et on
reproche du moins les générations
précédentes reproche à la jeunesse
actuelle ne pas avoir dit des halles ne
pas avoir de cause à défendre dans le
domaine politique ou autre c'est
peut-être assez aisément parce que nous
n'avons plus vraiment de maître à penser
tel que sartre a pu être un maître à
penser pour la génération précédente
on a dit que ça ferait le dernier maître
à penser et que l'on considérait comme
un monument et on avait l'air de forcer
on m'avait l'air de dire ça avec avec
nostalgie mais moi je crois pas du tout
il faut être nostalgique
c'est peut-être une libération qui est
pas de kepa de maître maître à penser de
monuments ce qui m'intéresse dans la
destinée de sartre c'est que dans une
première période de théorisation que la
liberté en at il et il s'est engagé et
je crois finalement cet engagement là un
peu perdus lorsque quentin quand un
philosophe quand un écrivain fait un
corps à corps avec l'événement je crois
qu'il n'est plus tellement capable de
s'en détacher et de nouveaux d'apporter
une nouvelle réflexion qui pouvait nous
servir à nous
nouvelle génération est alors que ça
puis bon été et aimant au niveau du
théoricien du philosophe et s'était
engagée voir aussi que sartre est
quelqu'un qui se prononce sur tous les
sujets s'est prononcé sur les jeux
olympiques il a il a été à l'enterrement
de pierre goldman il a et nombre de gens
calquent leur leurs réactions et même le
lan leurs pensées sur sur sartre c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui sait c'est qu'ils
participent à la vie de tous les jours
et son engagement politique est
important même pour les gens qui n'ont
jamais lu ni la traînée en huis clos ni
ni aucun autre livre ben pour moi la
mort de sartre ça représente surtout là
une deuxième mort des années 50 cela m'a
par exemple le conflit avec camus mumma
aujourd'hui la mort de sartre ce aussi
un peu deuxième mort de camus c'est
toute une époque qu'on n'a pas connu qui
était assez riche une point de vue
philosophique parce que sartre avait une
importance réelle
qui meurent encore une fois parce que
mon un start c'était sa philosophie tu
es un peu éclipsé était un peu tombé en
désuétude mais maintenant vous il ya
peut-être avoir un regain pour sarp
mepha il va être vraiment mort
oui nous l'avons dit en commençant
journal sarr fut d'abord un homme
d'engagement résolument à gauche la
plupart du temps l'extrême gauche il a
inspiré bien des passions en 68 et c'est
donc tout naturellement l'un des hommes
clés du mouvement de mai que nous sommes
allés voir daniel cohn-bendit qui pour
l'événement rompt le silence qu'il
s'était imposé
comment avez vous rencontré sartre pour
la première fois sa part est à je mets
en 1968 et c'était très simple j'ai reçu
un coup de téléphone un jour que sartre
désirais me rencontrer pour
m'interviewer c'était en plein pendant
les événements et c'est là que j'ai
connu personnellement sartre pour la
première fois alors qu'est ce qu'il a
représenté pour vous personnellement
bon sarthe d'abord il a présenté une
chose c'est qu'il m'a quand même donné
ma première définition de juifs en tant
que juif est en disant que c'est les
autres qui m'ont fait juif et qui me
font juif et c'est quelque chose que je
pense encore aujourd'hui profondément
même ce n'est plus que ça et puis
deuxièmement il m'a il a représenté
pour moi
quand même la guerre de la résistance à
la guerre d'algérie il a représenté pour
moi la résistance à la barbarie
impérialiste du vietnam mais au-delà de
ça il a représenté quand même
ce que je pourrais dire quand m
quelqu'un de choquant quelqu'un qui
était foncièrement minoritaire et qui
voulait être minoritaire pour lui ce
n'était pas un problème de rassembler
des idées de rassembler des hommes mais
de rassembler des idées croyez-vous que
parfois il se soit trompé dans son
action dans ses écrits oui c'est évident
comme tout le monde
ce qu'il faisait ce qu'il pensait
publiquement à haute voix c'est à dire
que on pouvait suivre ses démarches et
c'est ça qui le rendait aussi fascinant
maintenant
je crois qu'en ce moment il ya une
canonisation qui est en train de se
mettre en place tout le monde sort sa
belle phrase sur ça et je crois que ceci
aussi
est foncièrement sonne foncièrement
faute qu'à mes oreilles ça sonne ça ne
sonne pas tout à fait juste
pensez vous que pour les jeunes
générations il puisse encore faire
figure de symbole à l'heure actuelle oui
et non oui effectivement et si samedi
vendredi ou samedi à son enterrement
vous verrez qu'il y aura énormément de
jeunes qui iront à son enterrement il
fera figure de symbole
pas comme un guide ou quelque chose
comme ça ils ne voulaient pas l'être il
ne peut pas l'être mais il fera figure
de cymbales comme un homme qui désire
est fondamentalement la liberté et je
crois que dans ce désir il ya énormément
de gens qui se reconnaissent
un match d'homme de gauche donc
d'extrême gauche surtout mais aussi de
droite c'est le cas de jean marie benoît
qui fut candidat giscardien contre
marché il y a deux ans mais qui est
surtout un philosophe selon donc
entendre la réaction de jean marie
benoît
pour moi j'ai comparé un petit peu la
fin de sartre à celle de victor hugo à
fin du siècle dernier s'éteint un
monument à facettes aussi multiples que
victor hugo avec des inégalités du reste
semblable à celle de victor hugo d'un
poésie dans la littérature je dirais que
il restera plus par ses textes
philosophiques que par son théâtre et
que parce qu'ils allaient pourtant très
directement auprès de près ses lecteurs
et ses spectateurs je crois que est un
peu tôt pour évaluer mais je dirais que
son usage de l'histoire son engagement
en faveur de la révolution font partie
de ces grandes mythologies du passé
qu'on lira plus sartre comme un
littéraire que comme un philosophe dans
très peu de temps dans la mesure même où
ses choix son rendez vous manqué avec
l'inconscient son rapport à l'histoire
font partie je dirais de peut-être de
cette théologie de ces et de ses miss
s'est auto mystification je crois que
nous sommes dans une époque où sartre
est déjà un petit peu anachronique
jean paul sartre avec une grande passion
pour la presse il avait longtemps
collaboré à la cause du peuple et fut
surtout le fondateur du journal
libération libération qui prépare pour
demain numéro exceptionnel consacré tout
entier à l'écrivain et son directeur
guendi à gérard holtz ce que le
quotidien lui devait je crois que c'est
très simple on lui doit
résistance au froid xi
572 n'avait pas été là pour
pour donner au sein du gauchisme une
leçon de tolérance
sinon si ça n'avait pas été ce point de
rencontre qu'il était
au moment de sempy d après 68 je crois
que libération n'aurait pas existé dans
le numéro spécial de libération de
demain c'est au revoir ses adieux c'est
merci et on a essayé
à partir de l'oeuvre de sart donc de
constituer si vous voulez une sorte de
journal idéal composé par ça ce qui fait
qu'on a si vous voulez d'une certaine
manière on pourrait dire très
modestement sont des manchots choisi
mais je suis sûr beaucoup de gens sont
moins être surpris par exemple par des
manchots famille allende dans l'axé des
asiatiques qui a ça raconte la prise de
la bastille bon il deux journées en 1789
bons qui sont récemment ben page à peu
près de fulgurants mais je veux dire
qu'ils éclairent énormément ce qui s'est
passé en iran je veux dire je ne me
souviens pas et moi même j'en fais j'en
fait amende honorable si on veut mais je
veux dire personne je me suis pas
référer à ce texte au moment et je
m'aperçois que c'est un texte dresse les
uns qui est le plus proche son niveau de
l'explication du type de plus de peuple
en fusion quelques il a pu apparaître
par exemple au moment t en ou des
événements même qu'on voit au salvador
si vous voulez c'est un peu montré qu'il
ya des textes qui sont très vivants qui
sont à la fois des textes et d'une
profonde richesse compris même veut
sensuelle au niveau de l'écriture et qui
sont des points de départ c'est un homme
qui a qui parlent qui est devenu un
classique de son vivant et cas en
permanence refusé d'être d'être statufié
jédir des hommes comme sain dans le
siècle 1 n'a pas eu beaucoup et je pense
que c'est normal que pour nous il reste
pas vraiment des références pas mais si
vous voulez j'ai moi j'ai pas eu peur ce
matin un employé l'expression mais c'est
vrai qu'intellectuellement c'est un peu
un père forte
oui j'ai là les deux dernières
déclarations de jean paul sartre sa
dernière interview était pour un mensuel
homosexuel le guêpier c'est un regard
sabbatique sur les homosexuels et puis
une déclaration inédite
sur le chef de l'état une déclaration
que rtl a diffusé ce matin et qui ne
devait être diffusée qu'après la mort de
jean paul sartre il m'a rendu service un
jour et je lui suis reconnaissant cela
dit politiquement je ne suis pas de son
côté mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
que je n'ai pas de sympathie pour valéry
giscard d'estaing les deux déclarations
donc les deux dernières déclarations de
jean paul sartre
hommage unanime également à l'étranger à
l'exception un petit peu compréhensible
de l'observateur et romano qui est le
quotidien du vatican qui estime qu'avec
le décès de jean paul sartre disparaît
l'une des figures les plus en vue et les
plus discutables de négocia européens
aux maintenant d'écouter les réactions
d'allemagne et des etats-unis michelle
meyer et l'aqsiq
pour l'allemand de la rue sartre c'était
surtout cet homme engagé et peu commode
qui osa rendre visite et protester
contre les conditions d'internement de
bader le terroriste alors le plus haï
d'allemagne il reste et c'est essentiel
que pour l'intelligence allemande si
l'on peut dire sartre était surtout un
monument un maître à penser de la
philosophie de la littérature française
que l'on plaçait élise est directement
après heidegger le maître allemand le
fondateur allemand de l'existentialisme
il se passait en outre pas une semaine
sans qu'un magazine ou un journal
allemand évoque à la fois l'oeuvre et la
carrière de jean paul sartre ainsi en
est-il par exemple la semaine dernière
dans die zeit où l'on évoqué l'influencé
et déjà l'immortalité de sartre pour qui
selon cet hebdomadaire de très haut
niveau l'écriture était une façon de
forger le silence
américain
valérie de l'ouest
dans la presse américaine de ce matin
qui lui consacre de longs entourée de
colonnes à la une dans le muretain des
quatre colonnes en pages intérieures et
une page pleine avec 5 dans le
washington post les télévisions avaient
désir fois consacré de nombreuses
minutes à jean-paul stable avec les
américains voient surtout la disparition
de l'un des symboles de l'après guerre
et de la grande activité intellectuelle
du paris des années 45 les américains
d'abord le philosophe du refus et du
désespoir dont la plus en plus ressentir
jusqu'à la fin des années 60
tout en rappelant les affinités de sarre
avec l'idéologie communiste dit semble
surtout retenir pour ta grande tentation
intellectuelle
centre cannes tout le monde tresse des
couronnes des que disparaît un géant du
monde littéraire vous l'avez fait vous
même roland barthes la semaine dernière
et pourtant à propos de sartre quel bel
homme haï et quel homme qui savait
manier line j'ai d'ailleurs frappé
lorsqu'on a entendu tous ces gens et ça
c'est intéressant qui disait attention
on va le canoniser on va le récupérer au
vent en faire un monument et ils ont
raison c'est vrai qu'on entend déjà de
part et d'autre les phrase habituelle à
quel grand ami les mille et aimait il
aimait il était gentil quel grand
philosophe
quel grand écrivain et c'est vrai que
c'était sans doute un des plus grands
écrivains je dis bien un écrivain de
cette époque seulement il ya un peu
d'hypocrisie dans tout cela parce que
comme vous l'avez dit peu d'hommes de
son vivant on est aimé autant haye
détesté que là était jean paul sartre
est détesté par exemple par extrême
droite par la droite par même
quelquefois mon affaire de l'algérie par
même les socialistes des gens du sang
détesté par les communistes qui
aujourd'hui lui rendent hommage en
éditorial comme des gens de droite lui
rendent hommage et non seulement il
était détesté mais lui même n'était pas
un doux pacifique bien gentil qui
tendait la joue droite lui-même
rendaient coup pour coup et avec une
franche brutalité souvent d'ailleurs
toute sa carrière a été rythmée par de
fulgurantes polémique la polémique avec
céline la polémique avec mauriac à
propos de dieu y aurait beaucoup de
choses à dire d'ailleurs sur la vision
de dieu par jean paul sartre avec camus
surtout avec cana pas le communisme avec
camus je crois que ça fera beaucoup les
jeunes mais c'est intéressant parce que
là camus à vis de camus avait sans doute
raison sarthe reprocher il faudrait
aussi comprendre pourquoi à camus de
désespérer billancourt
parce que peut-être plus vite que lui il
avait compris l'aspect intrinsèquement
totalitaire du système soviétique donc
il ne faut pas réinventer un jean paul
sartre vous voyez en bonbon rose qui n'a
jamais existé d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens ont comparé jean paul sartre à
victor hugo et à voltaire et vous verrez
que beaucoup de gens pour le faire
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont quelque chose
en commun ces trois hommes c'est qu'ils
étaient obsédés fasciné par un problème
unique qui est le problème de la liberté
par le problème de la liberté de soi par
rapport à l'idée
d'autrui le rapport entre sa liberté la
liberté de l'autre entre la liberté
individuelle et la liberté collective et
cette obsession ce combat finalement par
la liberté eh bien ils ont utilisé tous
les moyens
toutes les techniques qu'offre
l'expression tous le théâtre le cinéma
pour jean paul sartre pas pour voltaire
la chanson le laissait le roman laisser
biographique la critique tout ce qui est
possible tout ce qu'il est humain de
faire sur le plan technique opératoire
sur le plan intellectuel ils l'ont
utilisée pour pouvoir faire passer ce
message de liberté et outre leurs
oeuvres écrites il y a une autre qui
l'ont laissé c'est l'oeuvre de leurs
actes et de la même façon qu'on ne peut
pas parler victor hugo si on isole
l'auteur des orientales que de l'homme
qui a taclé napoléon iii ou ou voltaire
sur l'idole de l' affaire calas on ne
peut pas isoler sarthe le romancier pour
régis pas d'accord avec ce que dit tout
à fait jean marie benoît le romancier ou
le philosophe de l'homme qui faisait
même si on n'était pas d'accord qui
manifestaient contre de gaulle en 58 qui
disait qu'il était prêt à apporter les
valises du fln qui a aidé goldman qui a
été à libération et c'est d'autant
je voudrais conclure là d'autant que
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec lui
il ya des raisons pas d'accord avec lui
même s'il s'est trompé bien sûr qu'il
s'est trompé en fin de compte à chaque
fois qu'un homme une collectivité un
peuple ont été opprimés foulé aux pieds
bafouée méprisé par tous juifs ou
palestiniens afghans ou lg rien par
exemple tchèque ou vietnamiens et bien
sartre a été du côté de celui qui était
momentanément la victime et on ne peut
pas en dire autant de tout le monde
voilà ainsi s'achève le match donc que
nous avons à notre tour rendu à jean
paul sartre aux matches qui se
poursuivra je vous le rappelle vendredi
sur antenne 2 puisque et apostrophe à
9h30 et la pièce qui suivra qu'il y ait
la chambre adaptée par michel mitrani
sont consacrés à jean paul sartre la
météo pour terminer tout à fait avec
beaucoup de retard et
excusons aujourd'hui le temps était
vraiment gris avec quelques éclaircies
notamment sur le bassin parisien la
normandie la bretagne la vendée demain
et bien le ciel restera nuageux avec des
ondées orageuses sur les pyrénées et les
régions méditerranéennes
sur le reste du pays il fera doux et
parfois même en soli de faibles pluies
risquent pourtant de se produire sur les
côtes de la manche ce soir c'est hervé
claude qui vous présentera les toutes
dernières nouvelles aux environs de
23h30 et puis demain notre édition de
12h45 aura pour invité jacques barrot
finissent de la santé
donald est terminée bonsoir à demain